hey guys Tim Farriss here wanted to talk
about note-taking I have what you might
call hypergraphia which means I write
all the time so I have hundreds of
notebooks so I feel like I'm in a pretty
good position to talk about what the
hell to do with lots of notes you need a
systematic way of filtering the best
stuff to the top of your attention at
least in some fashion so I'll show you a
few ways that I do that it's pretty
straightforward but the key to all of it
is multiple passes for almost all types
of note-taking and I'll describe a few
different types of note-taking that I do
regularly the key is multiple passes and
constantly asking in effect what did I
think was important to cool that isn't
that important or cool and then only
selecting the absolute and distilling
the absolute best so let's take a look
at something really small all right this
is the type of notebook that I would put
in a pocket a back pocket and this is
from an event it was actually a very
good event which was a Vanity Fair event
in San Francisco many years ago I want
to say around 2013 and I'll show you one
of the exercises that I like to do when
I'm feeling overwhelmed or feeling like
I need a reset which I do certainly
around New Year's and there are certain
seasonal times and I like to reflect so
I made a list and the the top is very
simple craziest things I could do or
eliminate or a limb in parentheses so I
wrote this very quickly and part of the
point of the exercise was to write
quickly and come up with all of the
craziest things I could do that might
alleviate stress now shut down blog was
one the next one because this is on
multiple passes stop all social media
scheduled for three months question mark
sell all homes stop using money stop
eating for 30 days cut off feet turn out
not to be something I want to do so I
didn't cut off my feet give away all
money buy one house with all money live
penniless for one year volunteer in a
retirement home
okay so the the volunteer in a
retirement home requires a whole lot of
explanation but I thought that it would
be invigorating and karmically wonderful
to do that particularly with ideally a
dog like my current dog Molly
nonetheless I did not cut off my feet I
did not stop eating for thirty days over
there later did multiple ten-day fasts
the point of this whole list is to come
up with lots of crazy ideas they can be
bad
they should be absurd they should seem
absurd and then perhaps out of all those
terrible ideas you'll find one that will
productively stretch your mind enough
that you find a solution would have
considered otherwise and in this case
stop all social media schedule it out
for three months was the one of the the
entire list and the list goes on that
end up choosing and it completely
changed how I related to using social
media and now that is a regular
component of taking off-grid time to
recharge and scheduling things in
advance using many different tools
whether that's buffer Edgar or zapier
like happier not zapier I said that for
automating a lot of this is also very
helpful from say Instagram to other
platforms and so on in any case that is
one example of note-taking and then
reviewing so the boxing and circling was
a second pass say a week later after the
event then the highlighting was yet
another pass say a quarter later I don't
know the exact timing on this because I
did act on it quite quickly but there is
a schedule for reviewing so you're not
just spewing onto the page and then
forgetting it with the exception of the
next thing that I'm going to show you so
this is the expedient in the pocket
brainstorm type of notebook and I'll
show you one more I'm going to cover it
up a little bit just to protect names
you can see here I've got Vanity Fair
event I have a couple of names at the
top that we're interesting to me Graydon
walter isaacson who I much later ended
up interviewing on the podcast who is a
brilliant guy incredible writer and then
a bunch of quotes so playing the ratings
game prevents you from taking risks it's
tedster and us now
Seinfeld took four years to find an
audience Mad Men was turned down
sixty-six times by buyers I highlighted
these they made three passes because I
felt like these were incredibly
inspiring reminders that overnight
success is rarely our overnight
successes and then the bottom right it
is action steps that I've listed and I
create these boxes in the bottom
right-hand corner I'm right-handed might
be easier on the left for lefties I
don't know but I create a box in the
bottom right hand corner of all these
pages so that I can put down potential
action steps the other thing that I'll
do is I will number these pages and a
lot of this I can't show you guys so but
suffice to say if you see that you see
page 39 it's kind of hard to see but I
will number the right-hand pages so one
two three four five and then I create an
index later which I probably can't show
you either it's just too much top-secret
stuff but I'll create an index in the
beginning of a notebook much like the
index that I would use in books that I'm
reading so that I can find highlights
later and you might ask well what about
the pages that don't have numbers that's
easy that's 0.5 all right so if the
number on the right hand side is say
page 2 if I flip it over on the back of
that page in the index would just be 2.5
so that's how I keep track something
like this the the next type of writing
that I'll describe is morning pages and
I'm not going to show you this page
morning pages popularized by Julia
Cameron introduced to me by a fantastic
writer and friend Brian Koppelman of
rounders Fame The Illusionist
co-creator of billions really fantastic
guy who's given me a lot of feedback on
my writing helpful feedback on my
writing introduced me to morning pages
as a superpower of sorts for many of his
high achieving creative friends who are
professional writers producers etc
and the purpose of mourning pages is not
to write down a bunch of stuff that you
will then vet 17 times the purpose of
mourning pages is very different as
Julia Cameron who wrote the artists way
might put it they are acting these pages
as spiritual windshield wipers so you're
taking the anxiety that you might feel
the distraction your monkey mind and
trapping it on paper so that you can get
on with your day and sometimes there are
gems that pop out but very often it's
really taking a nebulous fear or a
nebulous discomfort or fidget enos
whatever it might be and putting it on
paper first thing in the morning hence
the name of mourning pages she
recommends three long hand pages and
I'll just give you an example so this is
from July of last year and I'll put the
location and so on and there is a
morning pages workbook that I really
like but I just I just did it in a
notebook I haven't have here's what I
said I'm worried and anxious about the
notebook
the irony why well I have for six weeks
maybe a bit more based on the agreement
what's the worst that can happen really
and then I made a bunch of bullets spend
the summer working on it and dot dot I
have to push the deadline - fine
cancel the book and return the advance
fine I could still put it on the blog
next bullet make it super short and only
great stuff meaning only include great
stuff say it straight then say it great
that means getting the facts down almost
like a computer or if I get iPad
instruction manual and then trying to
improve the prose and say it more
cleverly put it more cleanly later next
I'm feeling uncertain about what to do
next or first each day and then a bunch
of bullets just get it all in one or
fewer places so gathering from notebooks
from digital from Evernote all into one
place order the main chapters write an
intro and conclusion question mark
remember the humor can include
ridiculous stories such as ABCDE etc you
can see and you can hear this is not
good writing and it's not intended to be
good writing it's intended to be brain
vomit
and that's the whole point so morning
pages I've found incredibly helpful for
stress reduction not principally for
insight or structured thinking it is
unstructured trapping of your neuroses
and anxieties in the amber that is the
written page so those are morning pages
and last but not least we got this guy
five minute journal and I will actually
read an example because the format is
very straightforward and I can show you
what it looks like this is what the this
is what the format looks like and I'll
get you a quote let's find a good quote
cereal so here's the basic format you
got the date at the top of the page you
get a quote sometimes good sometimes not
doesn't really matter but some of them
are fantastic then the prompts so for
the am doing this say in the morning I'm
grateful for one two three what would
make today great one two three daily
affirmations I am blank blank then after
it is complete say before dinner before
bed three amazing things that happen
today one two three
how could I've made today better one two
now this might seem simplistic it might
seem hokey but it is first and foremost
simple and complexity fails if I've
learned anything that is certainly one
of the things that I've learned and I've
used the five-minute journal for years
in different capacities and I am trying
to find one that I can share with you
but I'll give I'll give you an example
and there are many many many that I
could pull out alright so I'm going to
read and there are some guidelines that
I've been given and for many of these I
put prompts at the top that I want to
remind myself of so one of the prompts
that I've used is state story strategy
and they're arrows that point to these
that is a heuristic bard from 20 Robbins
meaning you want to improve your
physical state your energy level you
a state of arousal so to speak like
doing a cold plunge doing some jumping
rope whatever before you create your
story which will be enabling or
disabling or somewhere in between and
before you then create your strategy for
achieving a goal or problem-solving
because if you're in a depressed state
and this is something I've struggled
with you're going to create a disabling
or a victim based story and then your
strategy is really going to be very
narrow it's it's not going to be
particularly oblique or useful in an
unusual way if you have a heightened
state and then you can translate that
into an enabling optimistic story your
strategy will be better so I wrote that
at the top of many of these particular
entries blank entries before then
getting to them in any case so first
morning back Montreal was the day before
this is in 2017 I'm smiling at friend of
mine from Montreal I am grateful for and
again this might seem cheesy but for me
if I use certain tips and note-taking
for digesting information or
brainstorming finding insight that is
one type of notetaking I use the morning
pages for reducing nebulous anxiety or
worry and I use the five-minute journal
for focus improving focus and execution
and appreciation which you'll see so I'm
grateful for number one birdsong outside
beautiful number two fireflies and stars
last night number three
great great sauna times two before bed
and rain outside to lull to sleep so I
will write down any number of things
what has been a practice for me is
choosing simple basic things in other
words you could say my family my loving
family and that's great but that is a
big item and I have tried to cultivate
an appreciation of the smaller things
which could be this notebook the
convenience of this notebook and the
quality of the leather it could be one
of my favorite coffee mugs which is this
yellow coffee mug which has made many
appearances in my five minute journal
and that trains you I think to notice
the
little things which ultimately
translates to of course noticing the big
things but not vice versa
alright what would make today great this
wasn't 2017 create b.o.b forms
alright so b.o.b later became Quixote
which was tools of titans I believe that
was b.o.b that have been I think so I
think it was I think was tools the
Titans might have been trapped mentors
but I think was tools of titans if we're
looking at the dates look at TFS answers
shep honor that refers to chef Gordon so
this is the second bullet also T ot
spreadsheet all right so that's Amanda
Palmer I created and my team helped me
create different forms and spreadsheets
for digesting the hundreds of hours of
audio and transcripts that we have from
the Tim Ferriss show podcast
alright so create b.o.b forms look at
TFS answers and then number three was
email twenty new people to test the form
and these would be forms that are either
Google forms or wufu forms or something
like that that's it
what would make today great that is it
I'm very prone to overestimating what I
can do in the day and under estimating
what I can do say any year and the
benefit of the five ment journal with
very little space and very few bulleted
options is that you really need to be
concise you need to be succinct and that
helps me to overcome some of my lesser
tendencies next daily affirmations I am
forever forward M - no hurry no pause no
hurry no pause is an expression that was
taught to me by a friend former Navy
SEAL and also quite common in Buddhist
circles that I became very fond of and I
think that made it into tools of titans
and maybe into tribes mentors daily
affirmations I am alright second bullet
good at this four times before so just
reassuring myself that I can actually
complete books because whether you
realize it or not I find writing
extremely difficult and
and with great concerns of insufficiency
every time I tried to write a book so
that makes anyone feel better in the PM
review three amazing things that happen
today I also always try to include at
least one thing that is small Molly
that's my dog
heeling while walking around a few
different retail stores very basic Molly
used to have tendency to pull on the
leash sometimes still doesn't she healed
really well great that's bullet number
one next bullet per ton of all said of
all rava Khan who was a bit of an Oracle
an incredibly gifted and very smart
investor he predicted that Krypto was
gonna drop 30 to 40 percent and lo and
behold it did drop 30 to 40 percent and
he called it exactly number three
great late-night call with a dear friend
of mine that's it three amazing things
that happen today boom those are three
so I guess late-night calls probably the
night before that's okay sometimes I
make ketchup and then last but not least
how could I have made today better so
this was late June 2017 and it's good
for me to see this because I need the
reminder even though I've been quite
good at Thai trading back number one
don't use Kido as an excuse to drink 15
liters of coffee
that's the ketogenic diet and if I'm
using a low calorie keto diet to
transition into fasting sometimes I
compensate for that during the very
awkward kind of grey transition period
of keto flu to drink copious amounts of
coffee which always backfires and has
negative side effects so don't use keto
as an excuse to drink 15 liters of
coffee
I wasn't literally drinking 15 liters if
those in the Internet are taking that
literally next drink less coffee comma
used caffeine pills if needed
alright so coffees a really interesting
substance and has effects on the ability
to conceive pregnancy and so on that
seems to apply even if it's decaf as an
example so this was a period when I was
very very tightly wound on high dose
caffeine and wanted to make an effort to
decrease my coffee consumption and when
you use the five-minute journal
consistently what I will do then is say
every quarter go back and look for
patterns and to the patterns that I
noticed where what could I do to make
tomorrow better the two most common
answers were drink less coffee and wake
up earlier those were the two so I have
made concerted effort with
accountability to do both of those
things and that is the five minutes
journal so we have brainstorm insight
note-taking review write for answers
problem solving interesting goals and so
on we've got the the morning pages which
I can do here or in the more pages
workbook for reducing anxiety or worries
neuroses whatever it might be and then
the 5-minute journal which is very
helpful for both focus keep anything
simple and appreciation so you don't
have to do all three of these every day
I certainly don't I use them as needed
but when I do even one of these
consistently I see a dramatic difference
and not just my quality of life but
focus and ability to execute
consistently so hopefully that helps at
least one eat out there and thanks for
watching
you